we're almost done with 2017 but the ps4  is squeezing in another update before  the year closes out so what does it do  I'll tell you right now not much but hey  I'm Tony and here's the GameSpot news  update ps4 update 5.0 3 is out now and  it quote improved system performance and  that's it it's definitely not as  substantial as October's 5.0 update but  better performance is never a bad thing  the mandatory update clocks in at a  little under 400 Meg's and the install  should begin next time you log in  previous updates have brought better  streaming capabilities and enhanced  features to the ps4 so maybe that gives  you an idea of what can come and the  inevitable 6.0 update will eventually  get for now we've released our ps4 2017  report card and a list of the consoles 5  best games right here on GameSpot so  give that a watch and stay tuned as we  continue to count down our top 10 games  of the year  [Music]